bonsoir blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous alors expulsions réciproques de
diplomates
rien ne va plus la visite du chef de la
diplomatie européenne à moscou était
prévu de longue date
alors la question joseph à bord elle at
il eu raison de l'honorer et des tilles
assez préparée avec ce contexte tendu de
la sphère nouvelle ni oui bien sûr il y
avait tout à fait raison d'aller à
moscou
d'abord parce que la diplomatie ça
consiste à utiliser tous les canaux de
dialogue possible et par conséquent il
est tout à fait logique que le chef de
la diplomatie européenne utilise ce
canal se rendent à moscou à l'adapt à la
date prévue
évidemment son séjour a été un petit peu
perturbé du fait que après la conférence
de presse conjointe avec monsieur lavrov
il a appris que comme vous l'avez
indiqué trois diplomates européens
étaient déclarés persona non grata mais
monsieur morel est un diplomate tout à
fait chevronnés qui lors de la réunion
avec la délégation russe a évoqué tous
les points qu'il avait été prévu
d'évoquer et bien sûr tous ces points
ont été notés enregistrés par les
diplomates russes et figure donc
maintenant dans les dossiers russe
or la la la relation entre l'union
européenne et la russie est une
relations multidimensionnelles
il ya des sujets en effet de différent
des sujets de coopération aussi qui
fonctionne d'ailleurs toujours est ce
que monsieur morel à juste titre veut
éviter c'est que lorsqu'il ya un
différend est bien ceci empoisonne
l'ensemble de la relation
il veut éviter que à des accords sur un
point particulier finissent par prendre
en otage l'ensemble de la relation
bilatérale qui est en effet multiforme
et multisectorielle et je crois que ceux
conduits là et il a réussi sa visite
même si il a été un peu finalement
chahutée pour pas là pour l'argent que
je tiens a indiqué tout à l'heure alors
joseph bourrel avec cette visite et on
lisait cette expulsion dans le même
temps deux diplomates européens est ce
que ça ne
fragilise pas je ne prends pas alors
évidemment il va avoir une semaine un
petit peu difficile parce que quelques
députés au parlement européen des baltes
des polonais des suédois apparemment
lance une pétition pour demander la
démission que josep borrell mais josep
borrell comme je le disais tout à
l'heure et quelqu'un longue carrière
politique derrière lui
il a été président du parlement européen
il ya un certain nombre d'années et il
aura bien entendu le soutien de ce
département 6 po parti du parlement
européen c'est à dire des partis
socialistes du parti populaire et
probablement du parti centriste et au
parlement européen
on est dans un parti transnationales et
on ne représente pas en principe
uniquement les intérêts nationaux
par ailleurs les états membres bien sûr
on sait que les pays baltes la suède et
la pologne voulait tant pc borel de se
rendre à moscou et n'ont pas réussi et
ils vont sans doute en effet continuer
de critiquer ce voyage en disant qu'il a
été comme on dit maintenant humilié je
pense que les autres états membres et
notamment les grands états membres comme
la france l'allemagne l'espagne l'italie
la grèce le portugal qui actuellement
exerce la présidence tournante
soutiendront josep borrell et que par
conséquent il sortira normalement de
cette épreuve il a fait le job
il a fait son travail je ne vois pas
très bien ce qu'on peut lui reprocher
aujourd'hui et la question évidemment
qu'on peut se poser maintenant quelles
perspectives pour les relations entre
l'europe et la russie
alors pour ce qu'il est les expulsions
diplomates la russie a expulsé un
diplomate
évidemment les pays concernés
aujourd'hui ont annoncé chacun
l'expulsion d'un diplomate russe
c'est normal c'est la règle du jeu
habituel c'est la coutume et par
conséquent l'incident est clos
pour le reste évidemment il faut d'abord
partir d
factuel l'union européenne qu'on le
veuille ou non reste aujourd'hui le
premier partenaire économique de la
russie
c'est un fait c'est le premier
partenaire dans les échanges
et c'est aussi en stock le premier
investisseur l'investissement beaucoup
diminué bien sûr notamment en raison de
la crise économique mais il se trouve
que le principal partenaire économique
de la russie
c'est l'union européenne la russie le
sait est d'ailleurs poutine avait
indiqué lors de son discours en
vidéoconférence à davos il y à quelques
il ya quinze jours que la russie avait
envisagé dans les années 2000 de
conclure des espaces communs notamment
en matière économique avec l'union
européenne
la balle est dans le camp de l'union
européenne at il conclu et puis par
ailleurs il ya des coopération
sectorielle qui fonctionne qui
fonctionne très bien
le 20 novembre le 20 décembre dernier
par dont on a lancé depuis le centre
spatial européen de kourou en guyane
française
une fusée soyouz qui est une fusée par
conséquent russe avec succès c'est je
crois la 25e ou la 30e fusée qui est
lancée depuis kourou
donc le secteur spatial est un secteur
de coopération possible il a été évoqué
d'ailleurs par monsieur borel le secteur
énergétique ça va de soi et puis
maintenant le secteur sanitaire puisque
le vaccin scouts d'icv est en cours
d'examen par l' agence qui doit
homologuer les médicaments et les
vaccins dans l'union européenne et que
dès qu'il sera homologuée par cette
agence il est à peu près certain qu'il
sera utilisé massivement par les états
membres qui en ont besoin
il ya beaucoup d'autres sujets de
coopération y compris les sujets
internationaux et par exemple la france
coopèrent tous les jours avec la russie
au sein du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies par conséquent je pense
que là dessus monsieur morel pourra
faire rapport au conseil des ministres
des affaires étrangères qui se
réunissent dans deux semaines à
bruxelles pour préparer le prochain
conseil européen
en visioconférence à la fin du mois de
février il y en aura un autre en
présentiel
à la fin du mois de mars et en effet je
pense que c'est dit c'est la question
des relations avec la russie sera
discuté et puis en quelques mois
la france présentera son programme pour
son semestre de présidence européenne
qui va arriver au au premier semestre
au 1er janvier prochain au 1er janvier
2022 et il y aura évidemment un chapitre
sur la re la la la relance enfin
l'établissement d'un schéma de confiance
et de sécurité en europe qui est la
proposition que monsieur mac on avait
fait un break à brégançon à monsieur
poutine
à ce moment là ça fera l'objet d'une
discussion qui aura beaucoup désaccord
sans doute entre les états membres
mais il en sortira probablement quelque
chose merci claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales affaire à
suivre donc